this beacon yeah I probably should
approach it you know I want to spice
things up
yeah I mean why not it's been wet by six
months well Chris and I have been
together since June no six months you
know what you need to surprise his ass
for Christmas
yeah but he's flying home east with
family well that's perfect surprise him
before he leaves you know just leave off
on up Oh Jeff Mariah Carey you have a
key was please don't you actually that
could work cuz when he gets off from the
office he has to stop home and grab his
bags anyway but what should I do
baby I'm sure you can think of something
for him to honor right oh I get it
I know what I should do
[Music]
hey Chris hey Alex hope you had a good
trip back ease
I did thank you thank you and thank you
so much for getting my bags to the
airport because I missed I was like no
problem I did a message come in for me
by any chance
my girlfriend Amanda's been like I am no
but you did receive a package it was
really big so I had sexy Oh
be merry
[Music]